one knows was one of the main authors of
rohf a topic we've talked about a lot
this week he was a researcher at openai
and I believe also a grad student at
Berkeley as well cool and is now um I
guess the founder of the alignment
Research Center
thanks
um thanks for having me excited to talk
to everyone yeah so I I did my PhD
ethereum Berkeley I spent a couple years
at open AI doing more practical things
and then the last couple years I'm back
to doing theory on the research center
and today I'm going to talk about trying
to explain neural network Behavior what
it means to explain neural network
Behavior I wanted to give a warning that
this talk mostly contains questions
doesn't have a whole lot of answers
um sorry
so this is the talk about explaining
neural networks I'm going to say a
little bit at the outset about why I'm
interested in explaining behaviors of
neural networks
um so right now today we mostly train
intestinal networks as black boxes so we
estimate the quality or safety of a
model by having some imperfect
measurements and some particular
distribution we can sample in the lab
and then just testing like actually
making that measurement on that
distribution
which is not great from a safety
perspective
um so in particular we often can't
predict or detect when that model might
fail right so in the lab there was
something true of all the data we could
simulate some properties that the model
is implicitly relying on those could
break down
um and if we're treating the model as a
black box we don't really get to tell
it's going to happen until we see the
model actually failing which for high
stakes failures is potentially not great
um slightly more subtly if you have no
idea how this model is working you can't
really distinguish the case where the
model is operating as intended and your
measurements are detecting that from the
case where the model is just exploiting
imperfections in your measurement
we might hope that if we could explain
why a model Works
um
on some distribution then we can address
those challenges so either we can say
this explanation makes clear what are
the preconditions for good behavior and
so we can either predict how robust they
are or detect when they break down or it
can allow us to pull apart different
mechanisms for good behavior so that we
can distinguish them
this is sort of why I care about
explanation I think even if you don't
buy this at all because lots of
different reasons one could care about
explaining neural networks and not love
that they're black boxes maybe the main
takeaway here is I'm mostly interested
in explanation as some means to an end
um so as something which we're going to
use to address safety challenges rather
than valuing like human understanding of
models as an end in itself
it's an important context for the kinds
of notion of explanation I'll talk about
so overall outline of the talk I'm going
to talk a little bit about different
things you might mean by explanation
that I'm going to jump into talking
about heuristic arguments which I'm
offering as a notion of explanation for
neural net behaviors that I'm going to
talk about the research problem of
searching for a formalization of
heuristic arguments and then why you
might expect explanations to exist for
neural network behaviors
so I'm going to consider a toy setting
so I imagine we have some known Target
function G
we train a neural network to approximate
that function
maybe you imagine G is like here's a sad
instance one if it's satisfiable zero if
it's not satisfiable and then we're
given some set of parameters of the
trained model which in fact has high
accuracy so someone hands me like these
billion numbers and I would like to
explain why it is that say a Transformer
with those particular billion parameters
has high accuracy on this task
so say this is a toy setting the way in
which it's toys that I know the target
function G or it's often in the real
world will have something that depends
on unknown facts about the world like
some data distribution I don't really
understand but the nice thing about this
toy setting is that I have a precisely
defined statement that I'm trying to
explain right so I kind of a formal
definition of the data distribution a
formal definition of the function G and
then the actual neural net sitting in
front of me this is just a nice
precisely specified fact mathematical
fact that I want to explain
um I think that does simplify some
things I'm going to discuss but I think
the basic challenges of explaining
neural network Behavior do arise or many
important ones arise in this case I
think it would be very useful to be able
to handle this case I'm not going to
talk at all about a real unknown data
distribution
yeah so we're just to make sure I kind
of like understand what you have in mind
here so
if I could do that for this G
would that basically give you a proof
that P equals NP uh it depends what we
mean by explanation
so I mean if I had in fact a very high
accuracy then they'll give me a proof P
equals empty this model is not going to
have super high accuracy right if I
train a Statin model on like thousand
instance like thousand Clause side
instances you'll get some accuracy right
maybe it has like 50 accuracy it depends
on the distribution
um this would be a very hard function to
to learn and you probably would have
some you know it's as high as it is will
depend or how impressed you are it's
gonna be more than 50 hopefully 70 or
whatever
okay so then it would be like but it
would give you like
obtaining that like like performance
so we have our neural net which is
hopefully an algorithm and then this
would I don't know what an explanation
would do so what I'm not gonna discuss
is like what might we mean by
explanation
um
so the first the first notion I'll talk
about I'm happy to visit this doesn't
answer the question yeah but the the
first notion I'll talk about is just an
explanation something you give to a
human that helps the human sort of feel
like they understand why or how the
model Works in some sense this is like
the natural pre-theoretic notion this is
like what you would come in with if you
if you're just seeking an explanation
um so sort of stylizing how this might
work you could imagine assigning
meanings to neurons or directions in a
model an activation space look at how
those neurons or directions are related
to each other by the weights of a model
tell some story that makes sense about
why those activations like relationships
lead to solving the problem and then
maybe validate that story by doing some
experiments this image is from the still
circuits thread from Crystal's team at
openiak years ago
um here on the left we have some
directions or neurons in layer 4B which
they hypothesize represent Windows the
bodies of cars and wheels on the right
we have some neuron that represents
scars you can look at the weights
connecting these neurons to each other
and say okay Windows if they're above
the car excite the car detector Wheels
if they're below the car to cite the car
detector excite the car detector we can
tell a story that makes sense to us
about why this results in a better car
detector or like why this means that the
model will solve this task ultimately
classifying cars
sort of a paradigm example of someone
trying to look at a model trying to make
sense of what it's doing and tell some
story that leads to human feeling like
they understand why this model this
particular stat of whatever is 100
million weights leads to solving the
task
you can also Imagine doing that in this
Choice setting I described like for an
algorithmic task so if you imagine you
have some Transformer train to do in
this case an extremely simple task so
given two numbers A and B compute their
sum mod P
you can imagine someone handing you the
weights of that model they tell you like
look 99 of the time on randomly chosen A
and B you feed those into this
Transformer you get out there's some mod
P and you could try and explain why
and you might end up writing some you
know diagram of this form uh you say
like okay here's a story about how the
model represents the values A and B and
here we can look at the like set of
weights or the Transformations
implemented by the model and we can tell
some story why implementing those
Transformations would allow you to solve
this task a human can read that and say
okay I'm kind of convinced or they might
then do some experiments like well that
suggests if I do the following ablation
the model will stop working
at the end of the day it's not exactly
clear what like the formal type
signature of this object is but it's
something you told a human a human comes
away feeling like they understand what's
going on why this model works
so I'm pretty excited about research of
this form I really don't like the neural
networks are treated as black boxes I
would really love trying to understand
what's going on inside them I think
there are some problems it's the one
obvious problem is I don't really know
what understand means I think none of us
collectively like know that well what I
mean by understands in any of the
sentences I just said which makes it a
little bit hard to validate progress or
to scale progress or think about how we
automate this work or what we're doing
um our related question is is it even
possible to get whatever understanding
means when models don't think in a way
that humans would recognize like we
don't already know what algorithm we're
looking for
um can you break big models down into
small pieces and so on so I think these
are fairly severe problems in practice
to me as a theorist they're like really
bad problems I want to talk about like
properties of understanding that's very
hard to do and it's to find their
reference to how a human would feel
there's sort of one option for what it
means to understand or explain how a
neural network works I'm mostly going to
talk about other options but I think I
understand this one is important because
this is sort of the state of to the
extent that we explain how models work
this is the thing I most I most love or
like most gets at what I'm going for has
exists in the world right now
so I'm also going to talk about other
Notions so a second option is just to
prove that the model works
right so I told gave you this very
simple algorithmic task this statement
is perfectly well defined I can say
what's the probability if I sample A and
B are random and then I hand them to
this Transformer and then I decode its
output what's the probability that it
will be a plus b mod P
um in fact that probability is pretty
large you know more than 99 I could try
and prove that fact
I give several question marks on proof
because I think there's a very very
large gap between the kind of
understanding that we have when we're
looking at a neural network and trying
to say write a paper about
interpretability and the kind of
understanding that actually goes into a
proof I think this thing this diagram is
not that close to a proof of the
statement
but you could imagine going along these
lines making proving some Lemos about
how the activations relate to the
numbers A and B building those up as you
move through the model is ultimately you
actually have a proof of this theorem
yeah for this specific theorem if we are
able to sample like we can just throw an
IND sample from the distribution and
verify the statement yeah so there's you
can imagine
there's this tricky distinction like if
I want to know how good is my model on a
distribution which I can sample in the
lab I think the way you do it is you
just sample AMD you just check and in
some sense that's very analogous to what
we do with neural Nets most of the time
we can just treat them as a black box
sample some inputs measure the
properties of the input output Behavior
um so we seek from an explanation or
what I am interested in is something
that allows me to like understand for
example what were the conditions that
caused the model to work or distinguish
different reasons that the model might
have a property and this is kind of what
we might hope we get if a human is
looking at the model and understanding
what's going on
um it's unclear maybe if you get that
with the proof I'll just turn to that in
one second I do think it's the case that
sampling does not give you a proof of
this theorem right so you're not going
to be able to sample you will get some
convincing evidence of this of the facts
but you will not get approve certainly
well for you as a proof strictly better
than an exponent Nation or are they
incomparable uh so I'm going to offer
proof is like an option for what an
explanation is I think from my
perspective I proof would be a useful
form of explanation so I think a proof
does do this thing of like making
explicit the assumptions that were
required for the conclusion to hold so
you can say detect if they fail or
Reason about how robust those
assumptions are I think it's more subtle
but it improved does alive like tease
apart different mechanisms or like
understand in some intuitive sense why
this happens there are proofs that are
famously unilluminated right yeah so I'd
say there's a question of Illuminating
to whom right the proof is very
Illuminating to the proof of verifier
and not very Illuminating to me as a
human and so by moving from option one
to option two I have given up on humans
understanding these explanations
and in particular I think proofs of
neural network behaviors if we're able
to get them would be exceptionally
incomprehensible right so the proof of
like a property of gpt4 is going to be
you know hundreds and hundreds of
billions of pages just number after
number after number
so I agree in this toy setting I can say
exactly what the property is in reality
I don't know what exactly I mean
um like what does it mean to say that
gbt4 has some property
maybe a couple things for the purpose of
this talk I'm mostly going to focus on
this case where we know the theorem
setting I think it would be reasonable
to say I'm alighting some part of the
difficulty and we could debate whether
that's most of the difficulty or half
the difficulty or some fraction I think
there are a lot of useful things you can
do even in context where you know the
theorem statement so like for example
understanding the relationships between
different models like if you have your
you know gpt4 and gpt3 thinking for a
long time there's there are theorem
statements that are interesting about
the relationships between them I'm I'm
probably not going to dig into it and
just say like I'm giving up whatever
fraction I'm Giving Up by thinking about
this toy setting where I do know the
statement
yeah
a problem that looms large when one's
considering proofs is just is there any
short proof of the behaviors you're
interested in
um I don't really think you have any
theoretical reason to expect to be
entitled to a short proof of interesting
model behaviors I think is actually
pretty good theoretical case that
they're often won't be a short proof
um in practice it's been extremely hard
I don't think anyone has really proven
any interesting facts about interesting
models other than like robustness to
local perturbations or we could talk
about what's interesting but most facts
similar to like this toy statement like
people can't prove
I think I would be interested in proofs
I think proofs show a certain kind of
understanding of how the model works and
would help for certain kinds of problems
posed by you know let's be in Black
boxes and the problem is just they don't
exist
um or may not exist so instead in this
talk I'm going to consider a third
option which is I'm going to call a
heuristic argument that the model works
and by this I mean some kind of
deductive argument which follows like
formal rules of the game similar and
kind to the rules of proof but which
does not give you perfect confidence in
the conclusion so proof just settles the
question for example if you prove a
model Works you've kind of have proven
there's no backdoors you've proven
there's no other gotchas we're going to
talk about arguments which give you
Prima fascial reason to think something
is true
that's going to be the whole rest of the
stock
so I'm going to start by talking about
an example
one of the simplest possible examples so
imagine someone has given me the
following hard question if I sample
integer X at random between 1 and N
what's the probability that X and X plus
two are both Prime
this is the class example of a easy
question of course I'm extremely
unlikely to get approved for it's very
very hard to get a proof but we can
certainly make an effort to compute this
probability right I can say I know the
probability X is prime it's about one
over log n by the prime number theorem I
can easily compute X plus two is Prime
with probability one over log n I'm
wondering about the probability that
both of these things are true
simultaneously I have no idea
I don't know whether they're positively
correlated or negatively correlated or
what but I could make a default estimate
I've just assumed the correlation is
zero since I don't know if it's positive
or negative and call it one over log
squared f
I claim I'm going to make is this gives
you a good first pass reason to guess
one over log Spartan is the answer to
this question
so this estimate unlike a proof is
subject to revision
I'll say diffusable so for example if I
notice facts about the relationship
between X is Prime and X plus 2 is prime
that will change this default estimate
so unlike a proof this was just a
default that I can move from
for example if x is prime then X plus 2
is almost certainly odd so the
probability of X plus 2 is prime is
actually about 2 over log M the
probability of the random odd number is
prime that's a better guess than one
over log n it's a 2 over log squared N
is a better estimate than my original
one over log Square down
if I notice another relationship I'll
keep revising that estimate it's just
rules of the game for someone giving me
considerations and me revising my
estimate in terms of or based on the
considerations they've handed me
you can keep doing I think this game
eventually settles down at like 1.32 to
over log squared n is the best estimate
enough to integrate all the
considerations like this we can think of
which does agree with experiment is
probably the right investment
so this kind of defeasable probabilistic
reasoning is really common once you're
looking for it so I think it's perhaps
simplest in number Theory like in this
example of twin Prime conjecture where I
can take random models for the prime
numbers or for the solutions to do fancy
and equations or more often just random
ad hoc models that you can answer sort
of the majority of
you can settle most conjecture as a
number theory on the basis of this kind
of heuristic argument
um physicists are in the business of
computing things that they can't prove
it's not just because physicists are
lazy and don't like writing down proofs
it's because the kinds of methods they
use actually often don't correspond to
proofs they correspond to reasons to
think that the estimate is one way or
another which could be overturned later
and on rare occasions are overturned
later
um if you have some complicated
dynamical system and you want to reason
about it the way you reason about is
often by treating what is even the
deterministic system as stochastic and
using this kind of Independence
assumption
so I think I want to emphasize is these
are not Monte Carlo estimates so all of
these are like deductive arguments that
reason from premises to conclusions by
saying here's the relationship between
this and that rather than just sampling
a bunch of
crimes X and checking how often X plus 2
is prime so this is a category of
reasoning that is very different from
Monte Carlo estimates Monte Carlo
estimates sort of what we do in neural
network training this is something which
is structurally closer to a proof
although the level of confidence is way
lower
so if you look at all these arguments
like the kinds I mentioned on the last
slide they tend to share a lot of common
structure so you can cast them as
basically deductively valid arguments
the treat unknown quantities is random
even if they're deterministic
and they use some simple heuristics to
estimate the expectations of those
quantities
so perhaps the simplest heuristic is if
I don't know anything about how A and B
are related and I want to estimate the
expectation of the product I just treat
it as the product of the expectations
just assume the correlation is zero by
default
in the Prime's example I applied this
with X is Prime and X plus 2 is prime
it's slightly more complicated heuristic
is that if I know about some Factor Z
which is related both to AMD for example
suppose I know the covariance of Z with
a I know the covariance of Z with B
rather than assuming that A and B are
independent I can assume that the
residual if I regress onto Z is
independent so I can say suppose Z is
one consideration that drives the
relationship between them I don't know
if you really want to be able to verify
this equation then the same the
covariance between a and b a good
default gas is covariance of a with Z
times the covariance of Z with B divided
by the variance of Z
um so this is what we did in the case of
the prime number theorem with the with
the intermediate Z being X is Odd as we
understand how that Z drives both the
formality of X and the formality of X
plus two
so the nice thing or like a suggestive
thing about like these estimates across
many domains is they seem to use just a
few simple heuristics of this form
especially this bottom one
those suffice to get reasonable best
guesses in a really broad range of
domains
and this leads to the following
conjecture that motivates our current
work that all these heuristic arguments
are instances of some simple General
formalism rather than a bunch of
domain-specific tricks that work well in
practice
that is it's not the case that there's a
magical fact about the prime numbers
that the prime numbers behave as if they
were a random set it's the case that
there are some general principles of
reasoning which if applied to the prime
numbers yield these estimates
so by analogy logical deduction is a
simple formalism that's very broadly
applicable when you're reasoning
logically the hard part is like finding
proofs the hard part is not verifying
that the proof is correct we hope the
same thing will be true here right that
there's reason across many domains can
be unified in a single simple formalism
the difficulty is finding arguments not
verifying arguments
well I think that's plausible I think
the first reason I've already given
these arguments seem to have a very
simple and general structure even across
many domains you can put them in this
common framework they don't seem to be a
bunch of ad hoc rules they have to
empirically verify separately
another important point is they seem to
work by default so the story seems to be
often these arguments go wrong but when
they go wrong it's because there is a
specific reason that they should fail
for example you would incorrectly
estimate the probability that x and x
sure both Prime but someone can point
out to you the structure that you missed
and you can approach the correct answer
as you notice more and more relevant
structure
do you necessarily mean like Interpol
structures to human I basically only
mean structure for which you can
calculate right so somehow you've
recursively estimated something about
the relationship between a and z and z
and d
and then you may have no understanding
of what C is but it is simpler and
they're able to compute these
relationships okay so I don't mean I
don't mean structurally make sense to
humans I only mean structure that makes
sense to the rules of this game
okay so now stepping back and talking
about what we're looking for what I
would like to have we're searching for a
sort of simple program analogous to
approve verifier which I'm going to
denote as G
which takes as input some formally
defined quantity X you might usually the
twin Prime density or the accuracy of
some neural network on some distribution
a set of observations or arguments that
are relevant to estimating that quantity
X imagine is this like someone points
out if x is prime X plus two is more
likely to be Prime
someone points out a pattern in the
weights of a model or about the
activations of a model
and I'll put some best guess about the
quantity X which behaves like a
subjective expectation so behaves as if
it was the expected value of an unknown
quantity or random quantity X even
though an X maybe in fact is a
well-defined number it's just some
deterministic number but we're uncertain
about it
if we had such a g then we could cast
this goal of explaining neural network
Behavior as finding some Pi such that it
causes G to B have an accurate estimate
of the accuracy of your neural network
whatever property you're interested in
explaining or we're saying how is it
what does it mean to explain the fact
that F Theta and G agree one candidate
for what it means to explain is to find
a pie this kind of probabilistic
diffusable argument that leads you to a
correct guess about the probability that
F Theta NG agree
yeah so if I wanted to implement this G
I guess one thing I could try to do is
just train an llm to BG you could just
train a language model to BG I could
just uh give you a bunch of labels of uh
whatever X is true or not so I guess how
happy would you be with such a g uh
it wouldn't thrill me but I think it
could still be useful
I think this would kind of take you to
the same place so if you say just like
train a neural Nets Implement G this is
a very similar place to like human
interpretability research maybe it's a
bit better to Extended human
interpretability research isn't that
ground into the predictions and you
could really grind things through but
you have similar questions of how does
it generalize and like can we apply it
in cases where we don't have training
data and so on
um so I would be interested but I would
really love to have a g for which we
understand why it works in the same way
like we kind of trust logical deduction
way out of distribution I would love to
have a have a thing where we understand
why it works and contrastively out of
distribution
like the probability
right like you're choosing what
distribution you are you're choosing
what distribution you're evaluating the
accuracy of testimonism right that's
right and then
yeah so it's the typical setting here is
you have some phenomenon you can observe
in the lab so in the lab you have
something some experiment you can run to
suggests that your model is safe or is
competent or whatever and what we're
going to do is instead of just running
with the output of that experiment we're
going to try and explain why that
happened so you're going to say okay for
this distribution in the lab which I can
write like precisely here's why the
model works and then the hope is with
that explanation in hand we can then go
in the real world and we can say okay
this does or does not actually meet the
preconditions I can look at that
explanation say here's why the model
worked on that distribution here are the
important parts of that distribution
that caused it to work
um so this would be this property is
just some Behavior which we can Define
formally or we can actually conduct in
the lab I see but what if like when we
deploy the system the distribution is
really very different from almost
yeah
in some sense if it wasn't different I
wouldn't care about any of this if it
wasn't different from what you can do in
the lab I'd say just test in the lab and
work with the empirics so the the point
the points I mean you could have
different things you want out of
explanation and so I'm happy for
different people to want explanations
for different reasons and some may be
unsatisfied with this initiative
explanation but I'm interested because
an explanation for example lets you just
say like here's why the model works now
in a new input we can test whether like
that argument breaks down like can we
test whether that explanation breaks
down
observations or arguments
the question is can we constrain the
like choice of these pie eyes to be
things that are definitely relevant yeah
yeah um I think the idea is relevance is
kind of defined by whether it moves G's
view so I'm happy to say like it's fine
if you throw some irrelevant
observations in here those just won't
change won't change these view about X
so like essentially g equals then choose
like whether by
that's right she is just taking in all
these observations or observations about
the weights of a model I feel like hey
have you notice this weight is like
exactly 0.3 you'll be like I don't care
about that or I don't understand how
that bears on the question I missed
yeah is this similar to like mean field
analysis
analogous to it or a generalization of
it yeah I think the idea would be this
like mean field analysis is an example
of this kind of reasoning where it gives
you like here's a best guess a
reasonable guess ignoring some like
higher level correlations or like fine
grain correlations
um and so we hope that you could then
take that analysis and just throw it in
and say Here's the mean field analysis
and then G will output the we'll agree
with the media field analysis until some
new considerations come in
yeah uh so I just want to make sure I
kind of understand what pi is supposed
to be doing so
um you know like let's take this example
uh from my talk where you know there's a
Spam data set where like you are at
Presence of URL is highly correlated
with Spam yeah like uh and then we like
ask okay why is this spam detector doing
a good job and Pi is like ah because
like uh URL like one like pie brings up
some consideration of like URLs highly
correlated with uh the class label and
the model looks at whether there's a URL
and then you would use this to say oh
okay there's like a problem because uh I
could imagine some other distribution
where this is not true is this kind of
how yeah that's a great example
hopefully people heard it that's a great
example and like how we'd like this to
work so this phenomenon could be
something like in the lab I have some
data set I can confirm that on that data
set my model is successfully predicting
whether something is Spam I can try and
explain why that fact is which might be
pointing out like oh here's a feature
which is large on the spam data set and
small on the non-spam data set and which
the model is successfully picking up on
and then the hope is this has given me
I've now the thing I created was like a
statement of what it was about the data
set or some statement about what it was
about the data set that caused my model
to work this example is subtle because
of this like you can and once you're
working with the empirical data set
things become a little bit more messy
but that's the basic idea what we want
to happen in the end
a typical version of Pi would be here is
the empirical average of some quantity
over some some finite set it's totally
valid thing
so just stepping back and summarizing
this hope like I would love to prove
things about neural networks
um I don't think it solves all our
problems I think it was a big step from
black boxes I think that seems pretty
much completely intractable to me
um that said there's lots of domains
we're proving things as intractable
neural networks are not unique pretty
much any interesting system it's
impossible to prove things about
I'm a diffusable probabilistic reasoning
is pretty common and successful even in
many domains where proofs are
intractable I am concerned that it's
somewhat hard to scale this kind of
informal reasoning to neural networks
but we're used to dealing with proofs or
arguments that are say 10 pages or 100
pages long whereas an interesting proof
of say property of gbt4 would be more
like billions of pages that's not the
kind of thing where you can get by on
like a approximately correct
understanding
and so the hope is that if we could
formalize this kind of reasoning by like
actually constructing an estimator G
that may make it possible to explain
neural networks in a sense that would at
least be useful for some Downstream
applications
everybody that's all the rest of this
talk will just be digging in on this
problem of trying to formalize an
estimator G
how do you take any other motivation or
like why are you even talking about
these questions at this point
um and we'll just be moving more into
the Weeds now
um
so there's a complicated question is can
we think of general relativity as like
an estimator or like an approximate
argument or something about the physical
world I think the big complexity here is
you're sort of mixing together two kinds
of things when you talk about right when
you do physics you're mixing together
two kinds of two kinds of practice one
is understanding what kinds of laws
describe the world another is
understanding sort of logical
consequences or like how does how does
this model work what model is a good
approximation to another model and I
think the thing we're talking about here
is more about understanding like when is
one Theory a good approximation to
another theory and less about
understanding like scientific questions
about how the world operates
which is a lot of what physics does now
but maybe less of what physics did in
the early 20th century
and I'm going to talk about the problem
of searching for an estimator
and so roughly speaking our goal right
now is searching for some simple program
G analogous to approved verifier that
formalizes existing and formal arguments
satisfies natural coherence properties
and formalizes something called a no
coincidence principle which is roughly
going to be why we expect this to be
possible to interpret neural networks
I'm going to talk about these in the
rest of the talk
the most straightforward is formalizing
existing informal arguments so they said
this kind of reasoning is everywhere I
think we have like something like 100 or
a couple hundred examples of informal
heuristic arguments that a particular
quantity takes on a particular value and
often we don't expect those arguments to
be overturned by new considerations so
some examples are I described this
argument that the twin Prime density is
1.32. over log squared n
so that's like a case where we have an
informal argument we know what the
answer is supposed to be so we would
think that a formal system should
capture that conclusion
similarly we have an argument that the
probability of a hash Collision in shot
256 for randomly chosen documents is 2
to the negative 256. and we don't expect
to revise that estimate significantly
based on new considerations
so our hope is for any case where we
have such an informal argument there
isn't a formal version of the argument
so if I hand it to G it reaches the
right conclusion even if I also hand a
large number of Spurs arguments
so if I have a formal argument between
prime density should be 1.32
I should be able to give a formalization
of that argument to G such that no
matter what else you tell G it keeps
arriving at the correct answer
so I would be very happy if we could
Define such a g and if you had such a g
you might hope that then you could take
informal arguments about neural networks
and also submit them in the same way to
G and get reasonable conclusions that
match the kinds of conclusions a human
would think are Justified from those
arguments
are you assuming that c is the true
answer here
uh I think we often don't know just like
cases where it would be a big deal to
notice that c wasn't right it's like for
the twin Prime conjecture I don't know
if the real density is 1.32 but it's
like I would be a famous number theorist
if I had a reason to think it was
anything different so whether or not
it's the truth I think it's the answer
that the G should come to
I don't know maybe Shaw has a bunch of
collisions but
I don't know that would be a big deal so
you're happy if you're heuristic
argument system just converges on some
answers
uh yeah I think we have some intuitions
and we'll talk about coherence
properties I think we have some informal
the reason I'm motivated to explore this
is because we have some informal
examples that seem very accurate in
practice or like surprisingly effective
in practice
um and feel intuitively valid and so I'm
very happy if we just construct a formal
object that is agreeing with what feels
intuitively valid in simple cases so we
can then try and apply it in more
complex cases like analyzing a neural
network
yeah this Pi star that's supposed to be
if we have an informal argument we hope
it's very easy to turn that into a
formal argument like ideally it's
analogous to formalizing an informal
proof so if you give me like I think I
think a property or proof system should
have is if you hand me a math paper I
should be able to turn that into a
formal proof with like linear but
considerable effort
less yourself
oh
yeah so the question is give an X can
you find pi yeah yeah I think no it's
going to be really hard that's going to
be very analogous to finding proofs
right like given a true statement it's
very hard to find a proof of the
statement so the easy part is verifying
it so analogously if we succeeded this
it will not it will not resolve the
entire problem of interpreting neural
networks it will just give you a formal
standard for like here is here's a
machine which takes you give your
interpretation to can spit out a number
okay so I'm going to talk about an
example problem to ground a little bit
of the the rest of the talk
um so for a matrix n by n Matrix a we
can Define the permanent as the sum over
permutations of the product of the
entries in the assisted diagonal is like
like the terminate but drop the signs
I'm estimating permanence is very hard
uh even approximating permanence is very
very hard but it is possible given a
matrix to make all kinds of informal
intuitively valid heuristic arguments
for example
if I know the average value in each row
well the permit is just a sum of N
factorial terms one per permutation each
of those terms is a product of one entry
per row so if I know the average value
in each row and I multiply those that
gives me a reasonable estimate for the
contribution from a random permutation
If I multiply that by n factorial I get
some kind of estimate for the permit of
a matrix
so this can be either Justified from the
kind of simple reasoning rules they
sketched out before this is basically
one application of that basic
presumption of Independence heuristic
you can also check but if you feed in
like random matrices this thing is going
to have lower squared error than
guessing zero or whatever
analogously if I know the column
averages I can get an estimate that way
if I consider some finite set of
permutations over which I can compute
the sum so the permit is the sum over
all permutations if I take that sum over
some finite set of permutations that
also gives me a reasonable best guess
estimate for the permanent so all these
are quite bad estimates in the sense
that they will only reduce your error a
little bit compared to just guessing
zero
um but they are intuitively valid and in
fact do reduce your error if you're
trying to guess permanent on a random
Matrix
did you mean to scale your power
massively
by appropriate scale
uh no no so the permit is just the sum
over all permutations I'm kind of just
taking a sub sum a subset of the terms
in that sum of them dropping every other
term is zero all right
so you could instead scale but say
consider how many of the terms I took
yeah yeah if you do that you actually
got a much worse squared error than just
outputting zero and so it's actually not
correct in this case to scale it out
this is a bummer because it's like the
permanent's like two to the million and
you're giving an estimate of like 17.
yeah it's not a great estimate and
similarly if we can Factor The Matrix a
then we know the permanent is
non-negative we can Factor as BB
transpose we know the permanent is not
negative we can also get more subtle
information from this kind of
factorization the point is like we have
a domain we have a large number of
informal arguments you can kind of
understand intuitively or we can make
good intuitive arguments about what
these what your estimates should be
based on this data we like to have a
formal object that kind of formalizes
all of these conclusions and you can
hand these arguments in get out the
anticipated answer
thank you
so part of this we want we want to find
this G which captures like reasonable
best guesses based on the arguments that
have been supplied
we expect that a reasonable G should
satisfy a bunch of very simple coherence
properties so if you're talking about
your best guesses one property they
ought to have is they should be linear
so if I ask G to estimate like what's
the sum of f of x over every X
I should get the same answer as if I go
through each X independently ask G to
estimate f of x for each one and add
those up
this is like a very natural property
obviously expectations satisfy this
property it's reasonable to expect best
guesses to satisfy it there's actually
an incredibly stringent property
um so trying to do this while capturing
informal arguments is very very hard
um it's also a fairly important property
in the end for applications to neural
networks so if you don't if he doesn't
have this property it's much harder to
do anything with it doesn't give you the
notion of explanation which I want
that shouldn't be obvious
ly similarly we think that the new
statistic argument should generalize the
notion of proof so if I have a proof
that a quantity X is greater than C
then no matter what else someone tells
me so for any other Pi Prime I should
still estimate that X is going to be at
least C if I have a proof that X is more
than C it would be bad if my estimate
for X was less than C
that would be like a violation of being
intuitively reasonable
we can go on like this so we can write
down a bunch of reasonable properties
here's some iterate expectation property
that's just exactly analogous to a
property that holds for conditional
expectations which we would like to hold
if we're going to interpret this object
as like a subjective expectation
so I've said one of our desderata was
trying to capture informally informal
intuitively valid arguments another
desert Autumn is trying to match this
kind of coherence property
try I think in fact we cannot find any
function G that satisfies these three
properties
if you make these properties A Little
Bit Stronger you can prove that it's
impossible but a simple question and
self-contained is just is there a g that
satisfies these properties and a lot of
our time is seeking such an object
that's right constructing some
polynomial time computable G which has
the following three properties
or Pi is you're allowed to choose the
type signature of Pi it just has to be a
super set of proofs
so this will you could try and take pi
to be any proof but then you still have
to Define like suppose I have a proof
that the average number of primes is one
over log n or like I have my proof of
the prime number theorem that the
fraction of numbers that are prime is
one over log n i then can still ask G
what's the probability that one oh like
X and X plus two are both Prime and
those answers are going to be
constrained by linearity and by iterated
expectations and so if I take the
constraints just from getting the
answers to proofs correct plus the
constraints from linearity expectations
it's very hard to meet all those
properties at once
but not so hard we can show it's
impossible in fact we think it's
possible we can't find like counter
example these properties are kind of
been calibrated just to the level where
it looks like they should hold
probably the space of valid Pi is going
to be larger than the space improves but
you can take it to just increase
but like suppose that we say that such a
g exists but like so but empirically
when we actually try to implement G
there's no guarantee that
I think that we Implement is actually
the G that we put
uh
yeah at the end of the day we're gonna
have some particular G I'm going to try
and hopefully argue that g has these has
these problems
and then we would use this as part of
this uh Downstream yeah once we have our
explanation of neural net we can feed it
to this G and then we can talk about how
we actually use that to solve safety
problems so I'm not discussing here
yeah so I described One open question
which is just formalizing is intuitively
valid arguments this is precisely
defined but only with respect to a
database of intuitively about arguments
this question stands on its own to a
greater extent it's just can you find a
g that has these properties
to give like the flavor of the challenge
here I think it's normally very simple
to say what you should do in response to
a single argument so I said like if you
know the product of the row averages is
say 187 you're estimated for the
permanent should be about 187 times n
factorial this is kind of a reasonable
default guess if we just make this
presumption of Independence over and
over again
then we have harder questions if we ask
okay what if I know the product of the
Rose is 187 the product of the raw
averages but the product of the call on
average is negative 384. right it's not
obvious if I want to satisfy the kind of
properties on the last slide how I
should integrate these two different
kinds of information to make a best
guess
I mean I'm not gonna it turns out that
the reasoning these heuristics I
described on the first slide do allow
you to pin down and answer to this you
actually just add your estimates someone
can check that's like a good estimate or
it has lower squared error
you can keep going you can compute a sum
okay what do I do then
the answer is you use your Vibe of the
sum for the permutations you actually
computed use your default estimate for
the remaining permutations which you
didn't compute
it's okay if none of these numbers make
that much sense the point is this is the
kind of challenge we Face we understand
what individual arguments should do we
need to reason about how you combine
different arguments
this becomes much much harder once I
introduced I was able to merge these
three arguments if I had one more
argument that my Matrix has this
factorization it's no longer clear how
to merge that with the other arguments
this is probably the simplest case we're
unsure what the right answer should be
and so this is the kind of algorithmic
problem we're spending our time mostly
focusing on
so Paul I mean one question that we
thought about in the context of boson
sampling actually was uh suppose that
you've given a matrix like you know
various row sums and you also know
various column sums all right how should
you use those the best approximate the
permanent and you know our best
suggestion was to do synchron scale it
right so just you know but basically
normalize you know the rows normalize
the columns
you get these you know these rows and
these columns
I I don't know if that would be the
right generalization in this case yeah I
think that this iterative scaling
process even these questions where you
just have data about Rome column sums
are already interesting and non-trivial
yeah so I gave this as like a reasonable
answer this is kind of the first past
dumbest answer and you can definitely do
significantly better than this
um like if you condition additional
information about further computations
that you perform you should be able to
get better estimates I'm pretty
interested in talking about that in
particular like where you ended up on
that yeah
so in this case an interesting feature
is like this estimate must be
non-negative right we have a proof that
because it has this factorization it's
permanent is non-negative but the actual
quantitative considerations I have at
hand are going to end up with a negative
estimate event is large
so it's really unclear what I do right
in this case it's very it's very unclear
how to merge these different estimates
I could truncate negative estimates to
zero in order to generalize proofs but
if I do that then I will violate
linearity and consider expectation
property
again it's okay if this slide mostly
just kind of seems like numbers this is
the flavor of challenge though
okay
um
so those were the first two properties
when formalizing intuitively valid
arguments and one
um respecting coherence properties I'm
not going to talk about a third desert
Autumn which is maybe more
philosophically interesting
this comes from a paper gowers were
earlier this year
you propose this principle that if an
apparently outrageous coincidence
happens in mathematics then there is a
reason for it
so for example if you were to find that
at some point there stopped being twin
primes there are only finally many of
them then the claim is that's an
outrageous coincidence which would
demand an explanation is there would
have to be something someone could tell
you about why there are only finally
many twin primes whereas the twin Prime
conjecture does not demand an
explanation that's just a very obvious
natural thing to happen
this is a totally informal statement but
I think it's actually a pretty
convincing empirical regularity so it
has often been the case in the history
of mathematics that people discovered
that something that appears like an
outrageous coincidence happens and then
the mathematician set to work trying to
understand why like why is this Fourier
coefficient the same as the size of this
group representation and pretty much
always we end up with an understanding
that makes sense
yeah
is that impure conservation is
subjective to like survival bias really
like people are more likely to
find like explanation for coincidence or
in my sense is it's mostly like there's
an anti-survivorship bias here so if you
imagine someone has discovered an
outrageous coincidence which has no
explanation whatsoever that just becomes
this very interesting object for study
okay there are some like kind of weird
domains where this sort of thing happens
more and it's true the domains where
things don't work out nicely less likely
to be studied so there's some room for
it
um I've spent some time seeking and it's
actually there are like a few candidate
counter examples now but I think it's
like it's pretty sparse okay
I'm
I find this like a very natural
interesting conjecture even though it's
informal like I would love apart from
any applications in general and that's
to understand how to formalize the
statement
um and whether it's actually true just
like a very nice thing to be true
um for the purpose of this talk I want
to just translate that into the language
of this here stick estimation so I'm
going to say that a statement is an
outrageous coincidence if G thinks its
probability is less than 2 to the
negative length of the statement
um
and the reason I've defined it this way
is that if our probabilities were
calibrated then there should not be even
a single statement of this form which
ends up being true right if I take 2 to
the negative length of statement summed
up over every statements that's only one
so if these prob if any proposition has
probably significantly less than that
then by a union bound I expect none of
them to be true not a single outrageous
coincidence should occur
why is it the link
only to make this line true the only
reason I chose that was like if you
cherry pick like really complicated
statements you can find coincidences
that happen to be true like if I
consider it a space of a trillion
trillion statements I'd be able to find
one coincidence which had a prior
probability of only a trillion trillion
but if I'm only looking at 30 bit
statements there's only a billion of
them probably I shouldn't be able to
find anything that has prior probability
less than 100 billion
dang that was a good question to clarify
the converse of this is basically just
this no coincidence principle if
something looks like an outrageous
coincidence it's because you're missing
something there's some explanation for
why the phenomenon is more plausible
so that is a further property we'd like
RG to have this is a little bit informal
um but informally the property we'd like
is that for any true statement fee there
is a short explanation pie such that if
you give it to GG you'll say oh that
statement was not so unlikely after all
for example if I take the twin Prime
conjecture I just gave a heuristic
argument that actually was probability
one they're infinitely many twin primes
and so the claim would then be if there
are only finally many twin primes after
all there must be some short pie in this
case actually anyways some finite length
pile at least that explains why it is
that there's only finally engagement
crimes at least why that's possible
so if we apply this principle in ml
imagine that we have some model that
just has perfect accuracy on some
distribution so for every x f Theta of X
is equal to G of X for every bit string
if you were just pretending that F Theta
was a random function which is equal to
G independently with probability of half
on every input then this would occur
with probably 2 to the negative 2 to the
n
and as long as the number of parameters
is less than two to the N so as long as
we didn't have enough parameters just
memorize this data set this would be an
outrageous coincidence but the
probability it feels like it should be
zero and therefore there must be some
explanation right there must actually be
some structural facts about the
relationship between F Theta and G
which makes it not an outrageous
coincidence that they agree all the time
and this is the object we're looking for
so we'd like this is a property which
proves it don't have it's not the case
that if two functions are equal there's
a proof that they're equal but we hope
it's the case for some suitably weak
notion of this probabilistic reasoning
that whenever two things whenever a
function has a surprisingly large
accuracy there is some explanation for
that fact something someone could point
out some interpretability one can do
this is why we're interested in this
principle we would like to have this
nice guarantee if you have a neural net
doing something interesting in the lab
there is an explanation point
foreign
so for the last five minutes I'll just
talk about a theoretical problem sort of
another implication of this principle
um which I think I find quite
interesting and stands on its own
so there's another kind of outrageous
coincidence
suppose that I have a circuit mapping
two n inputs down to n inputs we'll call
it input X is zero if on input x c of X
is all zeros
so for a random function you should have
about two to the N zeros right you have
two to the two n inputs each of them has
a probability of one and two to the N of
being all zeros
again if you believe in this no
coincidence principle it should be the
case that you never have a circuit with
no zeros unless there's an explanation
recognized by G this is analogous to our
hope that there should never have a
neural net with surprisingly high
accuracy without an explanation let's
recognize veggie
so this leads to the following problem
but I find very interesting on its own
terms
so if we had such a g we could use it to
construct a polynomial time verifier B
which takes as input a circuit together
with a proposed explanation for why that
circuit should have no zeros
so that if the circuit in fact has no
zeros there is some explanation that our
verifier accepts so there must be some
structure in the circuit that explains
why it tends to not have zeros and our
verify will recognize that in output one
but if we sample a circuit uniformly at
random I will talk about distribution we
can come back to that
then with very high probability there's
no explanation
so not to be the case that if a circuit
has no zeros because that's extremely
coincidental there must be some
structure in the circuit that
distinguishes it from random and someone
could point out that structure to you
so if in fact the kind of interesting
estimator we want exists then there
should be such a such a v whereas I
think right now we don't know how to
construct such a v
and if you gave me any V I could easily
construct a circuit that will have no
zeros but will evade detection by or B
would you be satisfied with a heuristic
argument that says the probability that
c has no zeros is
would V be for the construction of this
B yeah oh yeah yeah I think these should
just be like if C is a thousand bit
circuit B should say well the
probability is more than two to the
negative thousand and then that's enough
because if you don't do that you're
going to get wrecked by a coincidence
right this first statement was
existentially Quantified over every
circuit so V needs to be very very
conservative
um
yeah
anyway so this is for the theorists this
is a problem I'm very interested in I
find it like again apart from the
application to neural Nets it seems like
it would be very interesting to find
such a V and I think it would capture a
lot of the difficulties we're interested
in here
um
I'd be happy to talk about it yeah so so
does
what's the order of the quantifiers the
first thing is to know what V does and
then I pick the circuit that's right so
we're looking for a v which has this
property universally Quantified over
circuits so the way the game works is
you come to me with a proposal for V and
then I get to either
exhibit a c which has no zeros but your
V doesn't recognize any proof or I get
to exhibit a strategy for producing
proofs for random circuits that succeeds
with probability more than one percent
I would be very excited if someone could
win that game I mean we are trying to
win that game this is one of the one of
the things we're up to
I think I find this I find the no
coincidence principle and this kind of
problem like kind of magical I think
this is not the sort of problem we have
solved collectively in the past all
right proofs do not have this kind of
completeness there's all kinds of
structure that proves to miss and so
it'd be very interesting to have this
kind of completeness statement
okay so stepping back summarizing this
whole story right I would love to
explain why neural networks work proving
statements about neural networks seems
like it would be really useful but is
intractable the feasible reasoning seems
like it's pretty common successful in
domains where proofs are intractable
it's not formalized
formalizing it may help scale to neural
networks but it seems right now like a
pretty hard problem and so most of my
life is spent on various sub problems of
this problem
um and the most ambitious hope is that
kind of any interesting neural network
Behavior which you can measure in a lab
and Define precisely must have some kind
of explanation that's recognized by G
and if that was the case that would be a
great step to be able to say okay now we
have a notion of success for
interpretability which is actually
possible for arbitrary models
cool that's all I got thank you
thank you
so I guess going back to G being a
neural network
um let's take yeah so can we look at
maybe go to your conjecture
um the big conjecture the the last one
you had with the circuits right so I
guess I'm wondering like uh is there a
way to kind of set up some sort of like
generator discriminator like some sort
of like kind of like pair of adverse
serial Networks
that are basically trying to do this
like do you think we could just test
this empirically with yeah I think you
can play this game you could play this
game either with humans or with neural
Nets let's just stay with neural Nets so
the way the game works with neural Nets
is I have initially a neural net that's
trained to Output one or let's say it's
trained to Output zero for random
circuits so for any random circuit in
any PI
then I have an adversary who's trying to
produce circuits with no zeros
this part is hard to play because
determining a circuit has no zeros is
obviously very intractable you can
imagine that the adversary I don't know
I actually don't know how you set up the
game because I don't know how you get
circuits you don't have no service if
you imagine you had such an oracle then
you could play this game
okay I see so you need some sort of
Oracle to do that empirical experiment
that's right I think morally you can do
this experiment with a property like
this neural net has accuracy 90 and the
reason you can't do that is like
understand and standard your
randomization conjectures you could do
this in a kind of cheaty way it doesn't
feel like an explanation so the reason
we've chosen a thing that's hard to hard
to do it's like less like what we care
about but it does give us a crisp
complexity theoretic implication that's
why the slightly unnatural setting
is there a place somewhere here for the
structure of the data uh in terms of
that you know if you if your data is
random for example the behavior of your
own networks is going to be completely
different probably nothing is really
good at work so where does the kind of
the structure of the data comes in with
natural you know the natural image
manifold or text manager
yeah so the idea is at the end of the
day what we want to do is like find an
explanation for why a neural network
works on some distribution and we could
also take an empirical distribution or a
finite set of data and properties of the
data distribution either one that's
formally defined or one that's defined
by a bunch of examples will be relevant
to that explanation so your explanation
might say hey look at all this data the
reason your model works is the data
contains the following regularity and
then because of that regularity and the
way that it interacts with the weights
of your network the outputs of property
p so the idea is properties of the data
set will appear as things that are
referenced by this explanation but
shouldn't it also appear somewhere in
the where you compute your coincidence
because
shouldn't that be a dependent on the
data yeah so in some sense we Define our
radius coincidence just in terms of what
G says and so sometimes when since if G
thinks it's really really unlikely
the crocking blog post is the closest
I've seen to something almost like a
proof I'm curious why like what you
think fails there or what's really
missing yeah so this is a
this this proof question mark or
slightly higher resolution this
explanation
um
so yeah if we start with this informal
argument here I'm not gonna go through
the details of the informal login but
some informal argument that this model
correctly does modular Edition I think
if you look at that informal argument in
this
the most obvious place I think this
maybe becomes a proof with quadratic why
do you call it informal though because I
mean the the argument is fine it's just
the connection to the weights right
yeah I think so you can view the
argument saying here's a formal story
that a particular algorithm works so
maybe in this column I have an algorithm
that actually works and I have a proof
of that and then I have some Clan about
how that relates to the weights I think
so that claim is is slightly informal I
think because it just it's quite
informal of how it handles the MLP and
the attention layer implementing the
nonlinearity I think that's mostly just
empirically estimated
um I think you could imagine proving
that I think when you try and prove
things like this you run into saying
things like I have a bunch of vectors
those vectors have small inner products
with each other and if you try and prove
that the way you prove it is just going
to be by exhaustive enumeration
heuristically it's a very clear White
Strip you take random vectors they have
smaller products it's not something that
demands explanation but if you want to
prove I think you need to enumerate
exhaustively through basically every
pair of vectors to say they have small
inner product and so the size of proof
you end up with is going to be
essentially the same as the size of the
Brute Force enumeration of inputs
um
so you could just say it's like a proof
but it has a key Lemma which is of these
n vectors no pair has larger product
which I think is hard to prove but often
very it's true of random vectors and
it's like kind of the defaults is for
them to not have large inner products
I don't know if that seems fair to the
authors is the key I believe that's an
important leap in the proof yeah I mean
I think so
the like the direction in which each of
these identities is implemented is
identified so like there is a claim that
like this particular direction in the
MLP is like where this computation is
happening I think the thing that is not
clear to me at least although maybe it
is clear to kneel is like
how it came to be represented like how
did the like uh you know gel use like
give you give you this and so that's the
place where I think you would need the
heuristic explanation I think that's
right I think there's a story about how
the representation works that story may
be formally completely accurate or like
approximately accurate and then I
suspect errors happen when you try and
actually analyze how it works and how
the error propagation works and so on I
expect that's going to be very hard to
turn into a proof
um there's one person I know one person
working on trying to do proof it's a
very small role that works in this way
so we'll see how good of proof they can
actually produce and
I uh I wonder like suppose that we are
training a bunch of like not very
rigorous arguments but like heuristic
and intuitively correct arguments
together will we be able to end up with
like actually wrong claims because we
are like adding kind of errors on
different steps uh and then uh as a
result suppose that we are searching for
such a proof that almost for every kind
of statement we can try to justify it
with a bunch of uh like informal
arguments and if that's the case then
like do we have to say for example proof
that g is only unique such that we can
avoid such situation or like what do you
think is a general strategy to mitigate
that yeah so I guess the first question
is once you're doing a bunch of steps
that are only probably accurate how good
is your conclusion and I think that is
sort of up to G to say here was a bunch
of steps each introduces error and do
error propagation
um and so we could talk about
empirically whether that works well and
this is related to this this optimistic
principle that actually the if something
non-trivial or surprising is happening
you do have to have the model itself has
to keep the errors under control
otherwise it will converge back to being
random
um I do think it's probably possible to
make an argument for arbitrary wrong
conclusions so this notion of like
proofs you can't prove a wrong thing I
think you can heuristically argue for a
wrong thing and so I think a lot of
these statements you have to be more
careful about exactly what you mean so
if someone comes to you you kind of need
to get more arguments not just one
you're not just trying to be accurate
you're trying to be accurate and then
robust to further argument
can we conclude um by just asking uh
this talk was rather theoretical and
your institute's called the alignment
Research Center I know in your head
these are very connected ideas but I
would love to hear just to finish this
off like what how do you see the
connection yeah so I think the the
connection primarily runs through not
liking like training and evaluating
neural networks as black boxes
um so there is a longer story about like
what we would actually do with these
explanations
um which in some sense is why we're
doing this in which I've completely
emitted from this talk I think probably
the most like credible way to
communicate how to say like look a lot
of us would like with explanations of
models
I mean it would be nicer if we
understood what we meant by explanation
and so despite there's a long story
about how we're actually going to use
these explanations which is roughly this
thing of identifying when an explanation
breaks down using that to flag when
something might be going wrong
um
yeah it'd be great to have explanations
hopefully we can use these to flag when
something goes wrong by seeing when like
the mechanics of the explanation no
longer apply but I think that link is
going to be hard to hard to draw quickly
okay
[Applause]
thank you